[Music]
some of the best food i had in india
was street food and every little food
stall
was cooking up something spicy something
delicious
little teaspoon of oil gonna toast off
a teaspoon of cumin mustard seeds
a touch of salt and pepper
lightly fry them off it's really
important to cook off the spices
it intensifies the flavor but really
draws out that nice
spicy deep rich flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind
nice and fine
onions in now
we're going to caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there get it nice and sort of rich
gas up nice and high and really
caramelise those onions now
once the onions have turned a rich
golden color that's what i'm looking for
that is beautiful add baby spinach
keep that pan nice and hot if you don't
cook it out
the actual breakfast ends up watering
when the spinach is cooked set aside and
it's on to the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alight four nice eggs
now give those eggs a little whisk a
little touch
of butter into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot
add a teaspoon of garam masala and
turmeric
cook that out now take your eggs
into the pan
almost gonna make like a really nice
spicy scrambled egg
turn the gas down
now as the scrambled egg comes together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter i quite like the sort of
creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there i get my spinach
chop up and then fold in
the spinach to your scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast
but it's served in these wonderful
little thin naan breads
this will work with any flatbread or
wrap you fancy and then lightly toast
your naan take the eggs off the heat
whilst you get on with the last
job add quick mint and spice yogurt
dressing
a couple of tablespoons of fresh yogurt
in there's always something to take out
the heat
then add chopped mint salt and turmeric
mix that in now
take a scrambled egg and half fill
and now it smells incredible get your
yogurt
down on top and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food in india how delicious
they can make
street food with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
once you try this spicy wrap i promise
you scrambled eggs will never taste the
same
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy
and the fish stays nice and firm the
secret is to season
the fish salt and pepper
that will draw out the moisture and that
will keep the fish really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic
now the batter as always when making any
batter
always sieve the flour i want a bit of
heat in the batter so
a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper season
the flour salt
and pepper and then
two teaspoons of baking powder this
almost lightens the load of the batter
now ginger beer
it gives that batter this sort of unique
spicy individual flavor
it's delicious with a fish and a nice
tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
sheen
give that a good mix you really want it
almost like the consistency of double
cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer
too thick and it actually prevents the
fish from getting cooked so you've got
to get it to that just that
sort of double cream texture let it rest
for as long as possible to give you an
even textured batter now the season
should have worked its magic and drawn
out the excess moisture from the fish
so it's on to the next stage fish
has gone slightly firmer perfect for
frying
start by coating the fish in flour
seasoned with pepper
pat that nice and dry into your hands so
you haven't got any excess flour
the flour stops the batter from running
off the fish
i'm just gonna check to see if my oil's
ready by putting a little touch
of batter into the fryer you see it
bubbling straight to the very top that
tells you that the
oil is ready never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if the oil
starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some
oil into it to cool it down hold the
fish by the corner
unless you put it in and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now in and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist your pan that stops it from
sticking
at the bottom oil should be gently sort
of bubbling away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no spitting of any water from
the fish
fry the fish for three to five minutes
gently turning halfway through
once the batter is golden and crisp it's
ready
look they look stunning it's like these
big crispy pillows of
beautifully textured cart leave the fish
to rest on a kitchen towel to blot
excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chilly
minted mushy peas
now how much you peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil and a nice
knob of butter into the pan
shallot finely chopped that adds a bit
of sweetness to the peas
slots into the pan
chili these are delicious when you eat
peas and they're slightly spicy
they're even better garlic
in the peas sweat off the chilli the
garlic and the slots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water
infuse with their perfect partner fresh
mint
stalks and all and then put your frozen
peas in
now what's the peas i've got nice and
soft drain them
now take off the stalks and then add
your peas to the shallots
i love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious onto your board
crush now you cannot beat crushed
delicious peas those peas
is incredible top with chopped mint
chilli minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms the importance of comfort food
if you're gonna do it do it properly
[Music]
oh
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic
and the best way to eat this is with
crispy buttered sauteed potatoes cooked
with garlic rosemary and thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
[Music]
level